it is opening day for the rangers here
at home right the home opener the
reopener however you want to look at it
but for the texas rangers the home
opener will go to mike boltonevich in
acquisition
from the off season these are his
numbers from 2019 21 starts
the payoff swing and a miss simeon down
on strikes now seventh pitch of the
at-bat on the way to hernandez
and got him swinging two strikeouts in
the inning
biggio at second but shed at first with
two down
there they go in the 3-2 swung on line
softly to right and that will drop for a
base hit
biggio will come in to score bushet
around the third
guerrero with an rbi single and it's one
to nothing blue jays man with a full
count he just fights it off
beautiful approach hits it into shallow
right field then
mishio scores easily to put the blue
jays out in front
payoff there it is oh strike three
called a delayed call
from our plate on fire we'll all get our
first look at steven matt's in a regular
season game for the blue jays
watching hyunjin ryu do it at times 2-2
fastball outside corner
strike three call two down plants that
thought in the hitter's heads when they
see that and then a fastball
right down the middle freezes him and
gets him
and what a way to get started for
stephen matt's one-nothing blue jays at
the end of one
now for those week five all outs
strike three call got a corner and maybe
a bit of a gift on that one
the 2-1 to simeon drilled deep left
field
it is gone up into the second deck
the second home run of the season for
simeon and the blue jays lead three to
nothing
and it's a fastball right out over the
heart of the plate and simeon's got
power remember this guy hit 33 home runs
in 2019
and this is a short quick swing to get
to the ball
and he hit a mile into the second deck
in left field
that's what we talked about they'd have
been making fulton evidence work and
throw a lot of pitches but eventually
you got to do some damage and they did
and now bishop sends a fly ball towards
the corner
and right and this ball is gone bisho
goes
back to back with simeon and it is four
to nothing
so cabin bigger this is another one of
those sliders that doesn't break and it
broke right into the wheelhouse of kevin
bizio
and abujas back-to-back home runs in an
early four-nothing
lead
robber down on strikes to end any
further threat
in the second now here he is as the
everyday second baseman in
texas jensen sliding to the inside and
matz hit the spot perfectly with that
fastball swung on and miss
i think pete walker is as good a
pitching coach as there is in baseball
and he's terrific at finishing off big
league pitchers
2-2 fastball gets the call on the inside
corner we talked about it so i
i would agree that you know you love to
get another inning out of them and
it looks good right there a nice way to
start the third his
sixth strikeout already
pitches in the game already and there's
a swing and a miss
strikeout number seven for fulton editor
just throwing some breaking pitches here
let's see what he does runner goes
pitches outside through the third
davis is a great base runner but gunned
down at third by trevino and the inning
is done jose trevino with the quick
release
and that throw right on time john davis
could absolutely fly and how about
charlie gilbertson
on the other end he's got kinder philip
at second gallow
at first the rangers down four nothing
and he shoots this up the middle that'll
pick up another rbi
kinder philetha is in gallow cruises to
third
nate lowe with 10 rbis in his first week
of the season
and it's 4-1 absolutely amazing that is
his ninth plate appearance
in which he has had a runner in scoring
position
hit second in the order last night one
two and a swing and a miss there kind of
a choppy awkward looking swing
by brock holt and he strikes out one
down
randall has walked and scored and also
flied out to center feet
the first pitch from cody and the slider
grounded up the middle of base hit
guerrero around third he is getting the
wave the throw is cut
and he will slide in safely on an rbi
single by grichik teles stops at second
5-1 blue jays
and it's a breaking ball that sits right
out over the heart of the plane he goes
right back
up the middle pick up another rbi this
base hit will extend his hit streak
to 11 straight going back to last year
and abujas get that run right back
02 on the way swing and a miss on a
fastball up above the belt
two down back at the scoreboard to make
sure he knows what the count is one two
change up and a swing and a miss
and stephen amantz just struck out the
side in the sixth inning
he's up 5-1 in the seventh two on with
one out
and the 0-1 to t oscar is swinging a
bouncer and he gets through culberson
into left field rounding third heading
home
and scoring standing up is biggio
as the blue jays have upped their lead
to six to one
culverson getting the start at third
base has had a couple of tough plays and
it's a change-up that
tayoska hits hard down to the third
baseman and he just can't come up with
it
this is past him before he can get his
glove down
well you want to make sure you get that
ice on the knee for danny jansen as
matt's makes quick work of
nate lowe free pitch strikeout his ninth
strikeout of the afternoon
that will be all they'll let him stay in
the seventh to get the one left-handed
batter and high fives and fist pumps all
the way around
and richly deserved what a performance
this afternoon by stephen mats
deep out to right field grichik is back
near the wall
scores hope in the second base with a
double
[Applause]
and it's a 6-2 ball game
so close and what a moment that would
have been still a great hit for
brock holt in this ballpark would have
been pretty amazing but nevertheless a
good swing as he drills this ball
the right center could look like richard
was about to make a great catch
as you said in and out of the glove it
looked like he had a beat on it the wall
helped kind of knock it out and keep the
rangers alive
again the 2-2 pitch and he got him
got a splitter that he swung over and
finally delis gets it done he strikes
out tavares and the blue jays
win the ball game six to two to take the
opening game of this series with the
rangers